you've been selected congratulations
you're a winner you've got free money
waiting for you your account has been
deactivated
click here to confirm your account
you've got a package waiting for you
all of these things are different forms
of phishing attacks some of them are
about greed and some of them are tapping
into fear but they're all trying to
social engineer you they're trying to
get you to take an action through some
sort of immediate motivation
so we're going to talk about fishing and
what's behind it and how you can defend
against it so one of the first things
we'll talk about was so is the social
engineering aspect of it social
engineering what does that mean well it
means that we're trying to get you to do
something it's a con game I tell you to
do something I give you a time
motivation or something like that the
clock is ticking in order for you to
take an action quickly and what am I
trying to get you to do as a result of
this social engineering well I'm going
to try to get you to click on a link
that takes you to some fake website if I
can get you there then I can get you to
type in your credentials and then I can
steal your account or I can steal
corporate Secrets or I could get enough
information about you in order to open
up a credit card in your name
another type of attack that I might be
trying to get you to do would be to
infect your system
if you click on this link or you click
on this file and open it it installs
malware on your system then I'm able to
see your credentials or I can take over
your system but these are sort of the
object of what the phishing attack is
trying to get now how about the
different types of phishing attacks well
in fact we've got phishing attacks that
are General in nature so they're sort of
the general phishing attack which is
pretty indiscriminate I'm just going to
send out if I'm in a Fisher I'm going to
send this out to anybody and see who
responds
then there's a more specific type of
phishing attack that we call spear
fishing
and in a spear phishing attack a
specially crafted message that would
make sense to you in fact the more
specific it is to you and your
environment the more likely you are to
click on it it doesn't have the same
widespread appeal but sometimes it's
more effective so for instance if I know
that you bank at a particular place I'll
send you the phishing email as if it
came from that particular Bank
now if you send a spear phishing attack
and it doesn't apply to certain of your
audience then they don't fall for it if
I know I don't have a bank account at
that place I'm not going to click
presumably but this can be very
effective another form of this would be
uh that it comes from your employer and
they know who you work for they could
even spoof who it's coming from and say
that it's coming from your boss and
therefore you're likely to click on it
so this is an example of spear phishing
um another variation on this is called
whaling
this is a special case of spear fishing
where I'm going after the big fish I'm
going for the c-suite I'm sending this
to the CEO the CFO the CEO somebody
really important with lots of
information and lots of access so I'm
going to put in lots of detail it's
going to be very specially crafted in
order to make sure that it's effective
there are other options here as well
that Fishers use SEO poisoning
foreign is another example where I put
up a fake website and then I do enough
to trick the search engine into
believing that my site is real and that
this should be listed higher on the
search results and then people going and
doing a search so this is not driven by
an email they go and do a search on a
regular search engine and they see this
in the top three and they click on it
when they're trying to get to their bank
and they end up getting to my fake site
and then another form of this is called
smushing
smishing is basically the SM part being
SMS so it's a phishing attack whereas
most of these these first two the
actually the first three are coming in
email this is coming of course into a
search engine and this is coming through
an SMS message but it's all intended to
do the same sorts of things that we've
seen over here
now what should you do to protect
against this well there's a number of
things you could do the most important
thing you could do in all of this is
stop and think
think about if it's too good to be true
if it sounds that way it probably is you
probably didn't win free money your
account may have been deactivated but
there's probably a better way to find
out than just clicking on that link
what are some other things don't click
the Instinct because we see something
immediate is to respond and click on
that if the the old Rule and you may
have heard this is don't click on a link
if you don't know where it came from I'm
going to suggest to you you never know
where it came from or at least in most
cases you don't because sending email
addresses can be spoofed I could send an
email that looks like it came from your
bank and you might not be able to tell
the difference I could send it as if it
came from your boss and you might not be
able to tell the difference so don't
rely on who you think it came from rely
on is this something that you feel you
should open or not are you expecting
this file are you expecting this link
that's a much better rule I think to
follow
other things you can do make sure your
systems are patched
that is keep the software levels up to
date in a lot of cases Fishers will rely
on vulnerabilities in the operating
system or applications in order to
infect your system
you can also do the traditional things
like antivirus or the newer stuff like
endpoint detection and response in order
to protect your endpoint your client
system from these
some other things you can do is use an
email security program something that
basically scrubs all the emails that
come into you
and looks for links to known fishing
sites and other types of of dangerous
places
and then another thing you could
consider is using a secure DNS
a DNS is the domain name server that's
what turns a
www.website.com into a numerical address
that's actually needed to send it over
the internet
so if you use a secure DNS it may have a
list already of known phishing sites
known malware sites known hacker sites
and if you click on that link when it
goes off to get a resolution to turn
that name into a number into an IP
address it will simply deny and will not
return that to you because it knows that
that's a dangerous place to go in the
first place IBM in fact offers one of
these it's free if you're interested in
it called quad nine and it's just
basically go into your browser or to
your DNS settings on your system and
change the DNS to 9.9.9
and it will provide that kind of
protection for you for free there are
other similar Services as well if you'd
like to take a look at those the bottom
line is phishing is a huge attack a lot
of people are falling for it and you see
this happening all the time you see so
many phishing emails coming in because
in fact people are falling for it don't
be a victim
thanks for watching please remember to
like this video And subscribe to this
channel so we can continue to bring you
content that matters to you